today's topic's super straight you guys
been asking us to cover this forever
yo what's up guys it's kyle royce
creator of super straight
so since tik tok banned me and basically
creator of super strength this man is
like the ceo of some board company
hey guys it's [ __ ] yo it's kyle
ritter here man [ __ ] ceo of super
straight like all
guys welcome here uh this is where we
like [ __ ] like heterosexual women bro
the sss
is right now on the the stock market all
right guys hey guys uh
i'm the manager here over at superstreet
welcome to our store uh hopefully you
have a wonderful time here where all the
heterosexual people can enter
hey guys this is my boardroom uh i'm the
ceo
welcome to superstreet home of the
superstreet
hi guys hi welcome welcome uh my name is
uh super straight this is my child over
here uh
anytime i attempt to upload an
explanation video they remove it
i'm gonna post it on youtube here so
first i'm gonna play the original video
of the super straight video and then
i'll play the explanation guys i made a
new sexuality now actually it's called
super straight okay since straight
people or straight men is myself i get
called transphobic
because i wouldn't date a trans woman
you know they're like would you date a
trans woman i'm like no
why that's a female no like that's not a
real woman to me like i want real woman
no you're just transphobic
so now i'm super straight i only date
the opposite gender
women that are born women so you can't
say i'm transphobic now
because that's just my sexuality you
know yo guys so as most of you know i'm
the original creator of the super
straight movement
the original video was privated but it
has been taken down by tick tock now
and with the extreme amount of hate and
threat sent to me my family and friends
i decided to make an explanation video
super straight was never created to be
hateful towards anyone especially trans
people
i created it because i was tired why do
people do that why do they do this like
thing where they shift the direction hey
guys this [ __ ] kyle ritter here i'm
the creator of super strength here at
super strength we try to make sure that
everyone feels comfortable and straight
because we just want to let you know
that here at superstraight.com
we're going to take care of all your
needs and wants super strength here to
take care of you
are you straight super strength super
strength
i don't i keep being super strange super
stokers yeah yeah which is like one of
the
gays thing ever that's the gayest thing
ever is it yeah i'm going to squirt you
yeah squirt you soak
focus squirt soak is super straight you
want those
let's go there's a pump and you do this
you never thought but anyways
hey you pumping okay you're pumping you
aim all right all right
this is my honest thoughts on the whole
super straight thing it's like guys if
you don't want to date people who are
trans there's nothing wrong with that
you don't have to and anyone who calls
you transphobic is being nonsensical at
the end of the day we all have
preferences all right if you have
preferences for certain genitalia i
don't care if you had
surgery or whatever it's not the same
all right have you seen it if you
it's not no i don't go out of my way to
yell this stuff i don't go out to trades
i don't care like that the only time i
have anything to say about this matter
is when people send me these videos and
like
if you don't do this then you're trans
it's like that's ridiculous that's
nonsensical
all right there's people who want to
date people from certain cultures
certain religions certain races certain
heights certain whatever
they don't want to date trans people
listen at the end of the day let people
do what they want to do now if you want
to have a discussion about why they may
have those views that's a completely
different topic
but to label someone something because
they're not open to certain ideas that's
ridiculous
so that's my thoughts on the matter and
i also think it's kind of odd to feel
the need to
get up on a platform and feel like you
have to announce this that's also
ridiculous to me
but yeah listen there's nothing
transphobic about the but the
principle of wanting to date somebody
who
who identifies with the gender that they
were born as in terms of like you're
female you identify as a woman like
there's nothing wrong with wanting
somebody that has that
experience like i would not personally
date a trans person why am i because at
the end of the day
me it's just not for me you want to ask
me our reasons it's none of your
business whether it's i want kids
whether it's i'm just not attracted
whether it's whatever it's none of your
business
we don't have to have that conversation
i understand why i understand why all of
this
is happening in the superstreet and
stuff like that i get that i get why the
sentiment is there i don't think it's
really necessary though
all right like you said it's just funny
that we're going to solve stigma by
stigma
there are people that are that that feel
that are stigmatized
because they are a certain gender or
they fit in what category
in the under rainbow now we're going to
stigmatize
other genders by calling them cis system
sisters
this and that and that so so that's what
we're doing so we're gonna
we we suffer from racism and we're gonna
just no no no what do you mean by
stigmatizing maybe i didn't understand
there or what they're doing just trying
to say i'm straight i wouldn't date that
like you said the reason your business
what's wrong with the cis hat and all
that stuff you don't like the expanding
of language
i don't mind like suspending language
that's what language does and that's
what happens in language
it's the way it's used how you're going
to categorize some people
and some words still stuff that's being
done to you you do unto others and i'm
like
that's not going to solve anything i
don't i don't like i don't like the
the logic of it it doesn't really solve
anything and what's being done to you
like yeah no you shouldn't be doing that
to me
but i'm gonna do it to you that's that's
what i have a problem with and then you
end up
with that people creating unnecessary i
don't understand what do you mean what's
being done to them what they're doing to
others can you explain whenever they
whenever they feel like they are being
uh put on the side like
they feel like they're being put aside
as trans people
they're being put aside and they want
they want to be
included and after that they tell and
that's not all
it's not everybody i'm not putting
everybody in the same case but then
after that
you tell people no you're you're that
kind you're this you're
that's the reason why you're like that
is because of your gender and your
biases and this and that and blah blah
and then you put them aside you put them
on the corner yeah you know what
you're over there but you're doing
you're invalidating
you're invalidating it's like you're
doing what you don't want to be done to
you
and that's why i have like an issue with
that that it pushes people to
create things like super strength
mindset i don't see that
i'm not gonna use the super straight i'm
not gonna use the flag i'm not gonna use
none of that
i am what i am and that's that's pretty
much that but i understand
why it's be it's because of what i just
explained the pushing and then
putting on the side and if everybody
goes to that phase whenever you're
marginalized
when you're marginalized the group goes
often to that phase
you know there's different phases of
being marginalized you know there's
knowing that you're you're you're
marginalized and then uh
react being very reactionary to the
everything and that's one of the parts
and at least to
people creating super straight dating is
inherently discriminatory
it's kind of how it functions and people
discriminate you in a dating sense
that's their choice
you know and if they don't want to date
you just move on with your date i don't
feel like
i don't understand why anybody would go
out there waiting like well you're this
hear that
if a white girl tells me she don't date
black dude you know what i say
cool and i move on with my dad i don't
try to figure out why if an indian
person says they can't bring home a
black dude you know what i think
okay i wouldn't go like that
i don't know what kind of cultural
reasons they got i don't know
that's their story who cares go find
people who want to be with you and
that's it pretty much and anybody who
doesn't but then also for the people who
don't want to be
you don't have to get on social media
and loudly proclaim it either way you
know i mean it's just like yo go do your
thing
all right everyone try to cause you
transformers like you're chatting [ __ ]
keep moving all right those people
nonsense
absolute nonsense don't listen to
anything that they have to say
okay nobody can tell you what you are
just because you're not interested in
them that's crazy
that's crazy talk so that's just my
stance on the whole thing
um would i call myself super straight no
but i would say i'm the [ __ ] ceo
super straight all right i'm the [ __ ]
inventor and i just want to let you guys
know if you guys go to
www.superstraight.com you guys get 50
off all condoms all right
all right only use for heterosexual sex
if they go into butt holes
they don't work super heroes of course
lady you got to be like [ __ ] super
straight all right if you got like a
buzz cut
gay that's not straight if you're vegan
what no not straight but then again if
you eat meat
gay not if you're a lady
you're just doing what god gave you the
right to do welcome to [ __ ] super
strength
we're only men x y and x x chromosomes
anyways this ceo super straight hope you
guys enjoyed today's video leave a like
comment subscribe
that's it imagine they claim our video
because he claimed uh he claimed that
he's the ceo of super straight
which he's not
[Music]
foreign